[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
we tapped into the group chat presented
by standul live in the bleacher report
app my name is cabby richards in the
middle is our betting expert in big bank
that is kelly stewart and the man who
interacts with winners
only please that is greg i breed
you're with us last week we went
head-to-head with charles barkley on our
chuck versus america segment
you voted for kevin durant to outscore
stephen curry
and here was chuck's take
take a closer look at chuck versus
america tonight's prop is who will score
more points
steph or k.d oh it's going to be steph
for sure
uh do you think catch steph could go
more than k.d oh yeah
he's got to he got to i don't think
that's the case though well well you can
hey you want to use the fanduel app
right now i'm already on him okay
america you are the winners kevin durant
outscored steph curry 22 to 20 in a
brooklyn win
and actually the next time we asked you
uh you voted that giannis
would outscore jason tatum chuck agreed
and the greek god
obliged 35 points to tatum's 30
meaning we're currently 2-0 against
charles barkley he is one-on-one let's
check the standings kitty
america we're winning and every time we
meet chuck
we're gonna be more and more generous
right g-money
oh yeah cabbie i'm always generous
that's true you know how i roll i'm
i'm always generous as long as you don't
cut me off cabbie
but with that being said with that being
said i'm in the comments right now
giving away some hoodies why not call
you greg claus even though christmas is
over
call me what you like call it what you
like anyway i'm in the comments i am in
the comments
zev dawg durant going crazy
uh durant is going crazy this year i
like i actually like that take because i
think brooklyn's gonna win the
the championship so i'm gonna give you a
hoodie for that nice uh here we go okay
um here we go here we go zion the goat
guy he said greg uh you know the the
greater than mj uh
shout out shout out to you bro that's
not deserving of money but shouts out to
you i'm in the comments cabbie yeah
every they're all just talking to me
give me takes i need takes in the
comments i need takes in the comments
and winners only please
come on don't you guys know the drill by
now let me give away some more let me
give let me get again
mccoy go lakers one more jonathan mccoy
go lakers
i'll give it to you for shouting out the
lakers uh yeah cabbie
they're all over the place in the
comments even even though that burns
your soul
to that somebody says that somebody
shouts out the lakers but
either way let's move on because it is
time for
our uh this week's chuck versus america
segment and it is a special one
i guarantee i don't know why i did that
but anyway last week
we introduced our new custom prop
and this is for all you quick hitters
that love that immediate action it is
the three by two presented by fanduel
will there be two three-pointers in the
first
three minutes of a game real simple two
three-pointers
in the first three minutes of the game
they were hidden
all over the place last week just ask
billy kelty
[Applause]
i have so much fomo when i see those
clips then
uh so this week we're getting charles
barkley into the action so we asked you
will there be two three pointers in the
first
three minutes of the milwaukee bucks
versus the miami heat game it's a
rematch of the east
the eastern conference semi-finals
tonight
will there be two three-pointers made in
the first three minutes
right now we we put a poll out on
twitter the audience is leaning
yes with 67
of
i'm gonna decide this right now we're
not waiting we're not waiting till after
the show
i'm gonna decide this right now
everybody get
into the comments let me know i need
yeses
and no's yeses and knows only we're
going to decide this right now tell me
if we're riding with i mean tell me if
we're riding the yes or tell me if we're
riding the no
now kelly you tell me what are you
thinking yes
or no this is tough greg because look
67 of america i really don't want to
agree with ever
this is uh is really interesting but
we're looking at the bucks
versus the heat both of these teams like
to run right out of the gate
i think we're going to see some high
flying offense in this first few minutes
until everybody kind of settles into
their rhythm and starts playing some d
i gotta go with yes here i mean i know
i hate to do it i don't ever want to
agree with you guys but yes
seems like the correct answer and the
milwaukee bucks like to stretch the
floor
you know brooke lopez is going to get a
look early on drew holiday their big
offseason acquisition can definitely
stretch the floor and then they have
chris middleton the all-star who shoots
at like a
45 3-point clip absolutely and then on
the other side of the
basket i can't forget about tyler hero
duncan robinson
gorham dragons there might be four
three-pointers
in the first three minutes absolutely a
yes for me
g-money how does the audience where are
they leaning
cabbie i just picked it up you know what
i just picked up the handy dandy ipad
and i'm in the comments
and they're all over the place i'm
seeing a lot of lots and lots of yeses
let me give away some hoodies
uh it's it's moving so fast i can't even
okay
uh aliyah g he said yes you're walking
away with a hoodie
ybs924 he said yes
greg you're the goat you're walking away
with a hoodie uh nani
one two three says yes you're walking
away with a hood
anybody that says something nice to greg
he just gives them a hoodie that's
called strategy tell him the formula
don't tell him the formula here we go
i'm giving away one more cabinet okay
last week
[ __ ] d mirand4 he's rocking with the
yes and he put up a gif
of tyler hero uh and and with that being
said cabbie i
i mean jimmy butler told us last year he
has a team full of shooters
i mean i i agree with him he does have a
team full of shooters and i i don't see
uh i mean i i actually do see the tip
off happening and they running the play
for duncan robinson off the pick
you know and he popping the three and
that's one down already so i'm rocking
with a yes as well
just like the audience uh so we're
rocking with the yes man
everybody's saying yes let's move on
okay america check out the pre-game show
on tnt
for charles barkley's pick chuck versus
america
our favorite segment here on the group
chat and make sure to get on
fanduel and bet the three by two it has
our name on it
be our underscore better be our betting
because we invented it
for you so only uh lock that in on
fanduel
for three by two and don't forget to
send us your reaction videos you're
talking trash to chuck videos
we love watching them all and we all
wish oh those are the best celebrating
all the trash talking talking to chuck
videos those ones
i can't get enough of absolutely and if
you need some ammunition
take a look at this
so i'm authorizing my agent mark
it's gonna be my i'm honored to work
with fanduel this is my first bet oh my
gosh
i want a hundred thousand dollars get
out of here a hundred thousand dollar
back i want a hundred thousand dollars
on the portland trail blazers to win the
west get that done
tomorrow hundred thousand dollars on the
portland trail blazers
to make it to the finals i
i just don't understand like how do you
come out the gate with your very first
bet for a hundred fans like 100 racks
like i just
there are levels to it and we might be
on
you can't possibly think that that is
chuck's first bet ever right you know
this
he's been doing this for years
okay okay on fanduel i was gonna say we
know chuck's been dropping
absolute bombs on bets for years my man
loves to gamble i love it i feel like
you have some insider information kelly
which you always he's my spirit animal
um so i mean a hundred grand on portland
to win the west i mean that is just
mind-boggling yeah cabbie cabbie cabbie
yeah yeah
yeah that that that is very
mind-boggling but i want you guys get
into the comments tell me if you think
chuck is uh losing his mind uh tell
me who's winning the west i need to see
it in the comments tell me
who's winning the west please tell me
who's winning the west in the comments
here are the okay here tell me that
uh i'm giving out hoodies kevin okay i'm
sorry you you're back to give me our
hoodies
you're the best all right so here are
the um the odds for the contenders in
the western conference
obviously got to start with the
defending nba champions of los angeles
lakers right at the top at plus
125 the lake the clippers in the mix
there at number two
the denver nuggets dallas mavericks and
then we go halfway down the screen
the portland trailblazers plus 2600.
if that bet cash is for charles barkley
100 bands that's 2.6 m's
2.6 million dollars if the blazers
can come out of the west good luck chuck
uh
kelly what is where are you leaning as
far as picking
a team to come out of the western
conference and then what are your
thoughts on charles
enormous bet so i'll give you my
thoughts on charles first now
the idea is this and i told you guys
this when we were doing the group chat
with mikey locks
you want to make a futures bet that you
can guarantee yourself money later on
down the road
now at 26 to 1 i get what chuck is doing
here my problem is
i don't think the portland trailblazers
can make it deep enough into the
playoffs
for him to find a good hedge opportunity
the other good news is for chuck though
he's rich enough he can throw a million
dollars down on the other side
and guarantee himself a profit so unlike
the rest of us
that don't have the ability to do that
he's probably sitting pretty so good
luck to chuck on his wager i do not love
it but at least he did it correctly
i'll give him that much uh so as i
mentioned we're looking for a team
that is going to go deep into the
playoffs and someone that holds some
value i was
trying to make a case for the dallas
mavericks at 10 to 1 but i'm going back
to the same team
that i bet back in august and that is
the denver nuggets at eight to one i
would like to get
a little bit better odds on this team
but i do think
that their bench is deep we know that
they have a couple of all-stars there
that are gonna make some plays
shout out to michael porter jr yes for
proving us yes
that in the bubble i do think that he is
going to be
a lot of help for this team again we
don't need this team to win the west we
need
this team to get into the western
conference finals and
so we can lock in a profit for ourselves
denver eight to one that's good chaby
before you jump in yeah i'm so sorry
ellie just said michael porter jr i just
got to say this
michael porter jr's barbecue chicken on
defense i'm sorry i just i just had to
say that yo
she dropped michael what that means
barbecue chicken on defense
if he's guarding somebody that's easy
workout clear mono imano
dribble dribble tween tween as he step
back easy bucky but then
but then michael junior could also give
you like 22 points
g-money he was just getting ready to say
what happens when he gets hot
when he gets out from three-point land
okay that dude's going to be on fire
like nba 2k where the flames exactly
thank you kelly i couldn't i couldn't
have said it better myself
for one time and one time only i'm gonna
agree with chuck with the chuckster
i like the portland at plus 26 i like
the portland bet
because they've acquired some pieces to
help them defensively daniel jones jr
and robert covington
dame lillard and cj mccullum they're in
their athletic prime it's time to go and
if
yusuf nurkic can stay healthy for the
whole season
the blazers are going to be a problem
this year in the western conference so
i like the plus 2600 i don't have 100
bands
so but uh my bankroll's a lot smaller
but i'm definitely gonna be sprinkling
on those blazers g-money how is so after
the audience
sees a hundred a hundred thousand 000
ticket from charles they've heard
kelly's thoughts they heard mine
where are they leaning right now you
know
they're leaning into barbecue chicken
cabbie i'm seeing a lot of gifts of
barbecue chicken next to the comments
so i got an idea
i got to reward them for the creativity
maddie g the real mvp you're walking
away with a hoodie
uh i'm also seeing a lot of
lakers in here i'm seeing man city jay
he said greg
rocking with the lakers uh i see nuggets
kelly i see nuggets
handy dandy ipad i think you won last
week
they're rocking with you kelly uh jalen
h
is also in the comments saying that the
warriors are winning the west come on
my heart likes that but my mind is
telling me no yeah exactly uh
cabbie i got one more i got one the
warriors need to win a game first before
they could even think about winning the
west we won yesterday kelly we won yeah
oh good
for the david beat the bulls we beat the
bulls all right yeah that's right
the buzzer how can i forget tj
tj muharram greg chuck has lost it
lakers winning the west again
i see a lot of lakers there's it's a lot
of mixed up uh it's a lot of mixed
emotions make smith's comments inside of
the comments
but cabbie with all that being said yes
sir i'm seeing lakers i'm seeing lakers
i'm seeing lakers and
i can't help but to agree i'm rocking
with the lakers here i say
that man lebron james is on a mission
he's on the mission cabbie my man has a
bum ankle and he's out there
levitating from the ground like it's
2003.
literally literally getting up off the
floor like it's 2003. i'm rocking with
the lakers the guys on the
the roster speaks for itself and the man
lebron is on the
he's on he's on the mission and the
lakers added a couple of really nice
pieces dennis schroeder and your boy
montrez harold so they won the offseason
now they got to get it done in the
regular season and in the second season
in the playoffs moving on um we asked
you in the
br app who's gonna score more points
tonight
this is box office zion williamson
versus devon booker i cannot wait
to absorb this game tonight send us your
ticks
sorry 10 and send us your takes with
this hall of fame point guard
chris paul running the offense some
people really like devin booker tonight
greg kelly cabbie loch ness monsters how
are we doing i'm out here on my day off
bringing you absolute hammer locks
that's the kind of guy i am
booker over zion tonight
oh we're up let's go
[Laughter]
hammer locks from the golf course it's
been nice to get a day off
mikey lost i'm confident that his
handicap
is north of 50. and uh
for sure he definitely shot over 100
today and after
dropping 32 on on christmas day
uh some people are leaning
on zion williamson
oh we don't we have the club okay so um
well well let's just so mikey locks
leaning on devin booker thank you for
checking in from the golf course
and then you know the young buck with
the big pipes who's the monster in the
middle
zion williamson so that is the bracket
devin booker
zion williamson g-money you're tapped in
with the audience you're chapped in with
the commenters
where are they leaning tonight uh
tabby let me let me prep them a little
bit because you know
in the comments they they they they be
all over the place so so let me talk to
them okay guys
i need you guys to tell me are we
rocking with zion williamson
or devin booker i need zion or devin
booker gifts
i need gifts only in the comments let me
know who we're riding with but
i'm not going to be like this big and
all you have to do is
in the meantime in the meantime between
time kelly
the floor is yours who do you think will
score more points
d book or zion honestly when i saw the
price here i got a little nervous i'm
like what am i missing
devin booker minus 142. i
immediately thought zion should be it
here look if we're talking about
nightly basis who is going to score more
points i think it's going to be devin
booker
but i will say this chris paul has
really taken over that son's offense
early on and i think that the pelicans
head coach is going to
feed zion the rock so guess what
i'm gonna not pay attention to the price
because if i think wrong i think long i
like zion williamson here hey shout out
to head coach stan van gundy and his
wonderful mustache in those mock
turtlenecks
you're right kels he's got an elite
talent in the middle
him and brandon ingram a wonderful duo
and then
there's lonzo ball who's gonna probably
probably film like five or six
alley-oops so for me
zion williamson easy had a double-double
last game 32 points on christmas day
give us another gift zion plus 112. i'm
rocking with you all night homie
cabbie oh my gosh kelly oh my god
i'm not even going to reply to you guys
let me get into this comments because i
told him to give me a bunch of gifts and
guess what i'm seeing
i'm seeing a bunch of deep book gifts in
the comments
because uh yeah i'm seeing it but let me
let me give away some hoodies
coco924 you're walking away with a
hoodie
uh uh e-e-y-o-r-e
and a lot of underscores eeyore you're
walking away with a hoodie
um elena elena underscore you're walking
away with a hoodie i got one more cabbie
one more i'm giving him one more one
more not darius garland i haven't called
your name in a while
uh fetchland shh you gotta ask the
producer if you can get a hoodie but
in my in my heart you can get a hoodie
anyway with that being said cabbie
i mean it's a landslide in the comments
it's a landslide in the comments
and i'm rocking with d book something
you guys
failed to mention one thing you guys
failed to mention
zion right now it's a number two
maybe three options depending on jj
redick's in the game there's no number
three option for zion come on my dude
zion zion's a number two maybe three if
jj redicks is in the game or not
my guy d book he's the alpha he's the
number one on their team
give him the ball so i see d book
putting up points i see him i see him
putting up points he's the number one on
their teeth
greg uh you're you're a lovely young man
and uh i taught and very charming and
charismatic but at times
logic seems to escape your thought
process
listen uh i know you love i know you
love
the group chat and we all ride together
as a family and
in this show and in previous shows you
lean heavily on the audience but i gotta
say to you man
be careful of where of how much you lean
on the audience
because we all know what happened last
week on the same game
parlay kelly and i gave you the keys to
the porsche
and it bare it didn't even get out of
the driveway we
tasked you to book the single game
parlays on fanduel
and bro what happened like we're like
you've been kelly 500 that you would hit
one five leg parlay this season and you
got out to
the roughest start possible bro look at
all those red x's on this ticket
control room be ready to bring that
graphic back up but
put the camera on me because i got to
let you guys know something what
you guys take cabbie you're
you're close with aaron rodgers you you
know him well
i'm gonna take a page out of his of
something that he said
relax please relax this is
only game one it's only game one
relax we're going to be okay we are
going to be okay
but uh bring that graphic back up
control room please
please bring that graphic i want
yourself again you guys attention all
right
yeah exactly i want to bring something
to you guys
attention you see dennis schruter over
one and a half
pointers kelly you know his name
i know his name but do you see that you
see the green check mark right there
all right you can bring the camera back
to me now put it back to me
yeah because i'm the one i'm the one
who said that that was gonna happen and
guess what it happened but
but with that being said i'm a man of
the people i am a man of people
you can look at the comments i'm a man
of the people greg are you throwing your
team
under the bus this is like all winners
only guys no
you know running them over no do not
listen to kelly guys
you guys know what's up i am a man of
the people okay i am a man of the people
and so and so i'm rocking with my squad
again i'm rocking with my squad again
captain
that's what we have just me and two what
do we got yeah that's what
i was i was getting there i was i was
trying to lead into it you
interrupted my intro but it's okay i'm
i'm i'm into it
i'm into it gordon drags over five and a
half assists
oh here we go oh here we go five and a
half
assists shout out to my guy buckets from
connecticut
reppin the state of connecticut shout
out to you bro uh
cabbie you mentioned brook lopez earlier
in the show i did
this is for you brooke lopez over one
and a half
three-pointers uh shout out to my guys
trends shout out to my guy trends from
jersey he gave me this
one uh he he'd be dropping a whole bunch
of trends in our group
that's a little risky i like the guy i
like the guy a lot okay a little risky a
little risky how is it he's gonna get
the rock
he will he will have opportunity
contradicting yourself
you just said he was gonna be shooting
threes earlier in the show
yeah but he's gotta make two in the game
i'm just saying it's a little risky he's
gonna get opportunities but
we'll see keep it moving all right
cabbie there's a reason you're not on
the winners
that's okay hey you great great i'm
coming for the winners only rankings on
sunday
oh you got to earn those stripes kelly
you got to earn those stripes
moving on moving on chris middleton he's
sitting at 20 points his over under
sitting at 20 points
uh we're going to hammer the over here
shout out to my guy brasco
representing the nyc i actually don't
put this one on me
he dropped this one yeah i don't hate it
either he's actually on my fantasy team
and he's been bawling
he's been balling this year it's on my
fantasy team shout out to him
uh that's for sure oh
heavy what what 31 on christmas day i'm
sorry keep
keep going i'm sorry i'm not really
that's you're just mad you're just mad
you're not on the rankings bro it's all
right
moving on duncan robinson duncan
robinson this one's for you kelly
we're going to go under three and a half
rebounds
we're going you guys are getting
rebounds
and i actually kind of don't like this
at all i kind of like the over
that's very odd ah well faye kelly
hashtag fake kelly get it in the
comments yeah
here we go duncan robinson is going to
have five rebounds today
all right we're going to see we're going
to see hashtag fake kelly need to see it
in the comments giving away hoodies all
right here we go
shout out to my guy luke from canada
he's from where you from cabbie
oh yeah from canada baby just one giant
country he's from where you're from
cabbie
hey to round this off we're rounding it
off this is my pick
it's me cabbie okay bam adabayo
over five and a half assists book it
he's gonna uh he's gonna be swinging
that ball around
uh that's it right there man that looks
like uh
i feel like we need a side bet great
because greg is gonna have one in every
single one of these
i think we need to have like a side bet
for if greg wins his
personally right because he was so proud
of himself week one
that was the only one i yo g money are
you up for us
since this is your pick in the five
always i've left
side bet hey i got the i got the mamba
mentality right now i'm
focused on that five hundred dollars
from kelly so i'm just focused on that
500.
i'm just focused on that five okay look
one no side bets no
focus one thing you may have forgotten
greg is that miami's big
offseason acquisition was avery bradley
who was a point guard
who will he's not going to take all of
the assists away from bam
but if he has two or three you know
assists on tyler hiro coming on a curl
or duncan robinson coming off a screen
or andre iguodala from the corner finds
a cutting bam
in the middle uh going to the hoop like
that's going to reduce the amount of
touches and the amount of
assist that bam adabayo is going to have
tonight against the bucks
so my dude i i'm going under for five
and a half assists
for sure wait
that just disturbed me bro why what do
you mean you just say
did you just say avery bradley's a
facilitator
is that what you're just trying is that
what you're trying to say right now look
all this he's not gonna mean he's not
not a facilitator true and that second
unit he's gonna have the ball in his
hands a lot and as you mentioned
uh in the rehearsals there's no jimmy
butler tonight
so somebody else is going to have to be
ooh
my guy averages one assist for the for
his career
what are you what are you talking about
right average is one assist
i would love to side bet but you don't
want to decide that that's fine
but that's just where i'm coming side
back side
hey we can side bet we can side bet this
one put the ticket up so i can show you
guys the odds cabbie we can side better
but i just want to show everybody the
odds
look at the odds that's a nice that's a
nice honey my g
100 bet you you're walking out with 25
you know i'm saying
25 you know that's life that's life but
you look at look at the odds look at the
parlay i'm loving it gabby
i am loving that i'm loving that i'm
loving it i i feel more comfortable
knowing that you're gonna go one in five
again uh listen
thank you very much for tapping into the
group chat presented by fanduel thank
you to our guest
mikey lox and thank you to all the
contributors on
g-money's winners only wednesdays who
helped to build the five-game parlay
shout out to brasco betts
remember what you learned today charles
barkley is really rich
and for the rest of us find some value
in your long shots
but do not bet the whole bankroll
alongside kelly stewart
and greg ivory my name is cabbie
richards we are leaving the group chat
peace
[Music]
you